NIGHT AT 7:00.
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT'S A BIG WEEK.
THIS IS THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF ROBERT MUELLER'S APPOINTMENT.
IT SEEMS LIKE A GOOD TIME TO
ASSESS HOW IT'S GOING.
THE INVESTIGATION IS COSTING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, IT'S USING
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF CABLE NEWS COMMENTARY.
OUR POLITICAL SYSTEM HAS BEEN
BROUGHT TO A VIRTUAL STANDSTILL.
WE STILL AWAIT THE
INVESTIGATION, ITS CONCLUSIONS.
WHEN YOU'RE IN, WHAT DO WE KNOW
SO FAR?
CERTAINLY NOTHING WE WERE
PROMISED AT THE OUTSET.
STILL NO EVIDENCE OF ANY PLOT BY
THE TERM CAMPAIGN TO COLLUDE
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT TO
HACK THE PRESIDENCY, TO BE
HILLARY CLINTON.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT RUSSIA
HAD ANY VOTE TOTALS FOR THAT
MATTER.
THERE STILL ISN'T ANY PROOF THAT
THEY ARE BEHIND THE HACKING OF
JOHN PODESTA'S EMAILS.
WE STILL HAVEN'T EVEN SEEN
EVIDENCE THEY HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THE DNC HACKING.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN CHARGED WITH
CRIMES, BUT ONLY FOR BEHAVIOR
TOTALLY UNCONNECTED TO HIS
CAMPAIGN OR BECAUSE THEY
ALLEGEDLY LIED TO MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATIVE TEAM.
IN THE CASE OF FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR MICHAEL FLYNN,
HE APPARENTLY WAS CHARGED WITH A
FELONY PERJURY CRIME EVEN THOUGH
HIS FBI INTERVIEWERS WE JUST
LEARNED DIDN'T BELIEVE HE WAS
LYING WHEN THEY SPOKE TO HIM.
SO IF YOU PEOPLE ARE HAVING
THEIR LIVES DESTROYED, BUT FOR
NOTHING THAT WE CAN SEE.
NO COLLUSION HAS BEEN FOUND OR
EVEN SUGGESTED.
IT DOESN'T MEAN WE HAVEN'T
LEARNED ANYTHING.
WE LEARNED THAT WHEN RUSSIA DID
TRY TO INFLUENCE THE CAMPAIGN
THEY WEREN'T VERY GOOD AT IT.
THEY SPENT A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY ON ONLINE ANTS LIKE AT
THAT ALMOST NOBODY SAW.
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE OUTCOME
OF THE RACE, THEY WEREN'T
COMPETITIVE.
THEY WEREN'T EVEN ALL ON TRUMP'S
BEHALF.
SOMEWHERE AGAINST TRUMP INSTEAD
OF BACKING A SPECIFIC CANDIDATE,
THEIR GREATEST INTEREST SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN SOWING CHAOS AND
DISUNITY IN THE AMERICAN SYSTEM.
MORE THAN ANYTHING WE LEARN JUST
HOW CLUELESS THE PEOPLE WHO RUN
WASHINGTON, D.C., R.
RATHER THAN ACCEPT THE FACT THAT
THEY CREATED DONALD TRUMP
THEMSELVES BY ABANDONING AND
THEN COMING TO DESPISE THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY THEY RUN, THEY
COULDN'T FACE THAT SO THEY
CONCOCTED THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
STORY AS A WAY TO SUSTAIN A
WORLD WHERE THEY DID NOTHING
WRONG AND THEY ONLY LOST BECAUSE
THEIR ENEMIES BETRAYED THIS
COUNTRY TO A FOREIGN POWER.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, RUSSIA WAS
ALL THEY COULD TALK ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY CERTAINLY DIDN'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE ISSUES
THAT GOT TRUMP ELECTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
DRUG ODs, A VANISHING MIDDLE
CLASS.
THEIR AGENDA OF WITTILY
REPLACING THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
THIS COUNTRY WITH IMMIGRANTS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
BUT IT HASN'T BEEN WORKING FOR
MOST OF HIS PRESIDENCY DEMOCRATS
HAVE LOOKED FORWARD TO
THE BIG MIDTERM WINDS THAT WILL
GIVE THEM CONTROL OF CONGRESS
ONCE AGAIN.
THAT'S THE WHOLE POINT OF ALL OF
THIS, BUT IT HASN'T WORKED.
THEIR LEAD IS DWINDLING.
IT'S NOW IN THE MARGIN OF ERROR.
THEY MAY NOT WIN BACK THE HOUSE
AT ALL.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE SENATE WAS
GOING TO BE BEYOND THEIR REACH.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC IS RECOGNIZED
THAT THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION IS
NOT WHAT THEY SAID IT WAS.